[Music]
good afternoon it is almost Christmas
and we are finally putting up a
Christmas tree and TIFF is busy cleaning
and we are struggling to survive both of
us ok so how did I do this I am
struggling to stand because I'm insanely
dizzy but I will try to explain to you
what has been happening these last few
days last week we went to two parties
back-to-back one was for the fifth team
and like you know the the group that
were investors in for all those food
concept places they had a big old party
maybe like 80% of people that went there
got sick the next day was the ginger
boys screaming and a good chunk of
people that went there also got sick and
then the day after the danger voice
thing was JK news somehow I was okay
until the like the last I don't know
like four or five episodes that's when I
started feeling my body shutting down
look at this cat they're not just a tree
that's the only tree we can have cause
of you guys
he's gonna knock it over anyway was
thing was I was fine
I actually had to cancel a dinner with
some friends because I started feeling
like wow something I'm coming down with
something
luckily I cancelled because the next day
on Friday was the beginning of my
nightmare and I started experiencing the
worst flu symptoms ever
luckily JC was taking care of me it was
really good to me thank you honey we're
doing great I'm hungry I can't eat my
throat is closed chantin are coming
they're flying over here I think that
his dad but he also has gotten sick
freaking today was the first day I woke
up and I felt like I will make it I will
live on me yeah today's the first day I
actually feel like I can get up because
these last however many days I've been
laying down sleeping trying to survive
and then this is the first date Casey
started feeling it yet ironically I had
a hard time getting up today and I had I
had to sleep in today I got my nurse now
I'll be here yeah but you also have that
oh yeah I also have a cold sores oh my
god it's so funny he just got the flu
I'm gonna give you a cold sore too he
has a cold sore I was like fixing up the
living room and I made it look all nice
and stuff but I ended up like like doing
something to my back like I pulled
something in my back so I'm like rolling
around trying to crack it I still can't
crack it so I'm like limping and stuff I
can't really do things properly I'm also
really dizzy right now and then what
happened you guys so this might be a
with that word TMI but so along with the
flu symptoms we both have like like soft
bowel movement
very very soft and tender and I thought
it was just a far as like a area bubble
and yeah stairs light switch on the
clothes for continuing the shores of
left house there's continued photo Chang
sign right now and then it went when I
came back down
tifa's asking would you go and I was
like oh I have little issues with rhythm
pants and some diarrhea stuff and then
then I was like for like two old people
like two senior citizens
you're pulling your back and I like
pooping my pants that's like old people
stuff I know it's a person's not here to
help us I know I know and then my lips
are all jacked up and I'm also sweaty I
have changed clothes like four or five
times because I keep sweating them like
all the way I keep soaking my clothes
it's so gross this has been the worst
sickness ever so whoever is responsible
for passing it on to everyone I hate you
and I hope you get your karma
cuz this has been the worst illness ever
David Julia Steve and Nicki Ryan Tim
those are the people that I know for
sure that were unnamed people yeah whole
bunch of the SIP team they are all sick
well the chant cleanse coming I wanted
to welcome them to our home with at
least some Christmas spirit it's not
like struggling really struggling right
now but trying to get the Christmas
spirit in here you did yourself a favor
by having a great foundation start ones
regardless if it's dirty or not and it
looks kind of Christmasy you know but
the Christmas stuff and so it's already
kind of half the color scheme that I
picked for this living room already
gives it a Christmas look so smart I was
all by design what see it's all
Christmassy we've been watching a lot
Disney Plus as well oh yeah nice Disney
plus something great the last three days
we watched Dalmatians a whole bunch of
Disney classic classes I miss Isaac I
keep having dreams of him being a baby
you know like poison a baby we've been
faced having a lot though but he has a
cough
we'll see you today pretty jacked up
yeah we will see him Christmas Day what
day of Christmas Day two days man all
right it's been about like half an hour
and look of what my beautiful wife has
done to the beautiful room in our
beautiful home to make it more
beautifully Christmas that one's new I
like that one I like this one too
look at right next to our painting
[Music]
yeah we did it I'm so dizzy we hug
I hope tang clan likes it if their mom
always goes above and beyond and like
she decorates like all really pretty a
chore we go so next year I wanted like
you know what's the word I can't you
know what I mean you want to level level
up that level of return the favor I know
next year in our new house we can do the
outside too
I can't wait to take my parents to Lucy
the house that's true everything about
the room looks really Christmassy so
this is the one right the second one
right there yeah that one that's our
baby
right in front of the well there's
people working dang on Christmas Eve
hard workers look at our backyard it's
high but yeah but see this is our home
yeah top-of-the-line stuff and then we
have a pantry
you're like a walking pantry I've never
had a pantry so I'm excited about that
I've never had a pantry never it's a
basic thing in the kitchen well you
would be surprised with basic things
that I am used to live in a house a big
house and remember the one that you
brush yeah it didn't have a pantry yeah
but there was no pantry just wash your
tasting and most you just use this piece
of appliance in the house will you get a
lot I don't we don't you have the
washing press before you can put it we
just rinse it know you've washed it
further you have a group of scrub up all
that all the stickies thing Bo you put
in there though why I only use it in
wintertime a few times to just to kill
the germs but I don't really washed it
I only
I only use the dishwasher want anything
you wash the dishwasher yeah
no into the living room this is
literally all we have for downstairs
this is a dining room area here that's
why I'm saying we're definitely
decreasing in space we're downsizing
yeah it's like a dining table right here
and then this is the living room but
they square footage-wise the same it's
the same because the the upstairs is
where we have most of it because you
know how the garage eats a lot of what
we would normally have but let's go
upstairs
[Music]
No you could do a six huh yeah
[Music]
so this is the thing we're saying that
we're gonna remove well we're gonna take
this off or and we're gonna put a TV
here and then we're gonna put like a
couch here so you could do like but you
can put a TV on top of this no we don't
want to do that because then we don't
want the too beautiful
no you and it's too high for us to sit
to take we're taking that out yeah can
you do not draw my still have no that's
already built like this oh yeah oh yeah
this is the master bedroom and then the
master bathroom there's a bathtub and
then look at the closet yeah yeah carpet
appeared all of it
upstairs is carpet except for the
bathrooms in the laundry room so this is
Isaac's bathroom this is a laundry room
so basically you just cannot even take
one of the couch from the whole house no
we're getting rid of them you have any
goats yeah yeah see this room has like
the most light my family
well if could the sun's coming from back
alongside yeah I wish I wish our living
room look this break it's too dark
you know what put back stairs maybe the
front lobby but then it's on the side
maybe don't do drape bunny on drapes
anyway cuz too much and they flop it
yeah I'm trying to find something that's
like like it lets the light in but gives
us privacy I think the one that we have
is good so we had to rush back to KC's
place real quick
in order to get dressed and drive over
to a very nice restaurant that is called
Martin G yeah Casey's been there before
he's driving right now yeah but I don't
know the way he's I never stole we're
still waiting like over 95% of all the
places I go to in LA I have no idea how
to get there unless I
which I went to where I thought
everybody there nowadays right we people
rely so heavily on GPS that most people
don't really like register like just
exactly how to get to that particular
place whereas like back in the day I
felt like this and we were kind of like
learning how to drive you I don't know
about you but for me like I was learning
how to drive before the whole GPS taking
like took off and like I remember like I
feel like that quest some stuff and
print it out and like actually follow
directions based on that quest and like
when you do that I feel like personally
I feel like I remembered how to get the
certain places much easier faster like
precisely the nowadays of the GPS we
take the wrong turn and just
automatically recalculates it all like
okay go I'm on the right path
anyways you took another wrong turn a
still on the right path cool and so
under snow like a real sense of learning
here yeah it's kind of like when you
four cell phones were thing you actually
have to remember people's phone numbers
or I don't have an address book yeah
really had that either true by now you
just have do the song of it yeah the
carry of a pencil or something with you
and write things down back in the day
yeah that's true bad because I usually
have a bag with me and I did do that for
a little bit out keep a little notepad
with the pen and I don't know I just I
hate pulling out my phone to write notes
I don't know why feels like a lot of
steps yeah but I don't we have opinion
no pad it's nice but also not very
conventional either we are on our way to
Barton G we are
it's Christmas Eve
then it a try Barton G's Christmas Eve
and
we are going to go out for drinks so you
might notice that Isaac is not with us
he's with his dad before Kris leave and
then tomorrow Christmas day we are going
to get Isaac so we'll see Isaac tomorrow
so tonight we are gonna go enjoy
grown-up festivities
bleep just gonna join us - for the
we are at 40 G's now
super fancy nice thank you
the nice coming out to fancy dinners a
nice excuse to dress up
[Music]
all right so we ordered Lobster pop-tart
this man doesn't understand the
presentation he doesn't he's the guy
that was kind of browning upon the
concept of this place but he's Ilan
snapchatting that's so true my dad is
never impressed with like these more
millennial i jinxed like restaurant
concepts and for sure if we walked in
here already like with
just spreading discrediting it but look
at you now phoning in they said oh the
size of a puff carpet it's not even if
anything that's more of a strudel
if the toaster strudel all right let's
cut into this or the crunch is nice look
at that lobster on the side Oh all right
let's try dip number one
[Applause]
[Music]
I was so concerned with getting a shot
of that spectacle and then even get a
shot at the actual food
[Music]
where we at now
la la cama watch out for the kid
[Music]
[Music]